here are this week's taught me  Elam you well dawn betrayed his crew in  the fate of the Furious we'll find out  in the series action-packed  eighth installment gobby more out there  for me in spark a space tale an evil  overlord has taken over planet vana it's  up to a monkey and his friends to save  the day we're taking it back her time  let's kick some asteroids the journey  and they will mean you oh nice a true  life story the lost city of Z tells the  story of a missing explorer looking for  an ancient city in the Amazon most come  back there is no turning back see what's  hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]